hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play works must die - I'm here
with Tom that's me that's him and we are
ready to roll
no looking at the spellbook this time
and this time we're not gonna not gonna
die corridors I like the sound of that
actually I was knocked unconscious and
you didn't check on me the master was
lying there hurt and you just left
uh-huh yeah sounds like him I'd have
done the same
- okay we're in trouble actually because
there are two doors behind I need more
time oh you can okay so one corridor one
of us will get one side and one of us
will get the other oh no I mean we could
block off one so - Bailey go down one
chord that makes that means it turns it
to basically and there are low ceilings
so okay so you want me to block off one
of these yeah once it gets to that but
for now just get this okay
and I got stairs to stairs oh they can't
get up those stairs no okay this is for
where you put archers ah okay let me
actually get that I want to take the
arrow wall off get archers on right I
guess my hand trinket is doing much
yeah I'm gonna use archers oh I get it
oh the old guy is building these places
he is yeah well I think that's what he's
doing I think that's why we're back in
the orc world protecting the actual
risks
what's to stop your character from going
crazy again trying to take over the orcs
nah she doesn't have that control helmet
anymore that that it I I guess made her
go crazy
okay either way where are we gonna set
up uh I mean I could slow them down this
whole hallway just let the archer take
them apart oh let's go eat flesh comes
out put some slow right there yeah that
took all my money
really yeah those things are expensive
yeah well they're effective true all
right let's just go all right I mean the
first one is gonna be that bad
which side do you want me to block off
left or right okay I'll block off left
then Breyers uh yeah ah come on
that's why we needed archers even it
near one Yahoo five John it lost count
well they got three back get back
okay okay I'm gonna go stand by the
backs no go to work
nope nope nope
are you attention
now how many was that ah
this guy's
oh holy crap HUD leave it that far
crap crap crap crap crap crap
crap crap crap crap crap
we go back back
I can knock them into the lava pits
that's useful oh it can you knock the
big guys I cannot overlords is there a
mic bigger gobble biggie I'll crack they
split in this oh crap oh yeah they do
but I got
could you charm the day yeah or at least
I assume I can I haven't tried
that's that's totally to handle well
it's easy when they're just the only
ones there if there's a bunch of works
though well with my stuns it's fine
don't run from the back just here
guys I gotta know
whoa - be some co2 record
look at all those combos
more fliers
Oh guys with raining
the small ones are really easy well
funny one class takes I would like nine
yeah
I wish said
another big guy yeah stunning right next
to the grinders that's good 100 G damage
to them yeah
it just does constant damn I filled it
until it uh you know get stuck
oh oh okay well good they give us a
pause here that means we can block off
one alley all right I'm gonna block off
the left side everyone have it come the
right yeah I got plenty of money
I do too so I hope
did you see if there was going to be any
more of those explosive ones I did not
check okay
I'll just block them off over here so
it's closer and it all come this way ah
I'll move these once you get
I was one of you Barney about 1800 okay
okay it should be fun oh this that's
actually I see I think I see a lot of
gold coins no that's a lie no that was a
lie
oceans nevermind okay we're good
whatever you guys ready breaking through
okay you get one end I'll get the other
Oh
these arcs are pretty foolish places
send all these forces all at once on the
first way yes just like every other
perfect
Oh oh good I thought they were getting
through
hey guy
now the Atlantic with something idea no
good and not even a little bit of
problem they didn't even reach our traps
no I'm gonna spend some of my okay I'll
hold them off just in case I just get
some flyers for my I don't wanna buy it
good idea
we're actually doing good it's
surprising amazing
ha
well it's pretty easy so far another big
guy I'll charm
that was easy yep I bet they're gonna
come from front now or both of these
yeah you get that end just get both of
these okay everybody
welcome to killstreaks city population
no problem so far it almost seems calm
yeah okay a little too easy
I guess you know later on
with this right here
let me know when you want to replace
some of these cartridges oh I think it's
fine for right now
Oh done and done easy oh now it's gonna
get hard yeah they gave us a pause I'm
gonna put some more archers open the
walls here let's see I think I should
refocus over here cuz we got lots of
traps over on this end yeah let's see
I've got enough for four slow traps
however you wanted oh you took away your
fliptop yeah I sold them for the other
side well six archers shouldn't be bad
I don't know those those flying ones can
sometimes kill the archers pretty fast
especially when they're close together
as it defined the way they are now yeah
I'll put some more flame traps here oh I
only have enough for one you cheap
bastard whatever oh just go it's not a
big deal okay you want me to get this
okay
Danya
suckster business
yeah let's go go get that money
flyers to the air archers are dominating
yeah
just make sure that the Flyers don't get
a chance to kill the archer
nothing from behind yet
Wow that's a lot of dead
I love that AoE
big
I hope there aren't any other even
bigger ones are coming from hon like an
earth king or something they're my I
feel good
charm one is dominated
yeah but the charm loses its effect
right when they split so then you have
two that aren't termed can you only turn
one is if not plastic
no it's just one
okay
I kind of like these haymakers yeah yeah
first yeah but they look cool that's all
that matters
oh yeah that's right I remember - do you
owe my kid night didn't make are you
sure you don't want this one I'm fine
yeah okay it's not me that needs it does
the kill kill donor pretty cheap where
they come from
Oh
[Music]
up above
up and I'll nose
pawn right others God
this still seems pretty easy they are oh
I got it but yeah so far so good
maybe we're actually getting good at
this maybe they haven't started sending
on both ways yet at the same time I mean
yeah these guys just have no chance
Oh three
those guys just slow
yeah they already go slow to Kinlin
ha easy wait Oh got it look good alright
he's easy marginal way they're getting
into that keep it coming
[Applause]
there's a cap on the number of artists
is there I don't think so father was
back up back in the first one I had a
really good thing where I used a lot of
paladin Guardian for the best huh I
didn't know that you could
paladin's lose this thing where you feel
like a big dick
when you were near them
Boyd everything goes went toe to toe toe
I never used paladin so I never got to
try that
where are they I know welcome
oh yeah
no way
you're probably from back end along
better safe than sorry though
whenever I ever played it soon
dah-dah-dah-dah you want a couple of
these coins no you keep it alright
I just don't least man I got so much
money been fine I'll buy some archers
then they musta upgraded to damage the
art died everything
yeah they're pretty effective especially
when they're out of range
I wonder if at the end like the holy guy
that would be a twist which says revenge
yeah he doesn't seem to like us very
much haha
well I don't know I don't know why so
disappointed in your character because
he managed to stop them pretty well yeah
you need to do a good job but then again
he is kind of a dick
true but I mean that doesn't really
matter as long as you saving the world
man that's a lot art how many did you
place Oh like ten almost there
what there 100 they can go through
barricades
oh that's but but they don't go towards
the rift
look at all this one's all yours buddy
mine said they were years
yeah there I was just reaffirming your
statement
I wish I did hoods headshot bonuses
Danish yeah wait you don't know oh
really
yeah it doesn't matter where I hit okay
that's why I just spam well I guess
that's good and bad but whatever alright
alright to more ease they're probably
gonna start sending them from all three
at once ads no problem yeah I've got
I've got so much
I'm seriously willing to bet that we
could have like totally mortified
we could probably ignore both sides up
Guardian limit reached your le gardien
yes wait can I put still put some oh I
can't put some either so applies to both
of us I want to make this amazing
warning may cause
one two
-
well did this guy the head that'd be
nice but I can't apparently
and from the back No
I feel very safe in here do you odd
considering there are machines of death
everywhere around
I think I will upgrade the ice next is
it it increases the damage done by a lot
and it stunk basically it's done in
how much mana 2d is very little what
lose my Nana barks that's it well that's
cool as much as a stunt so
and last one they better send from all
three or I'm gonna be kind of bored yeah
I hope so
I mean bond on wave
nope just thats how its gonna leave a
mark clear
all humming ah
yeah this is almost not fair
oh now they're coming okay now you go
ahead
now
Oh
dah dah all done how's your end no
problem no problem
they're barely getting through barely
getting through they shouldn't be
getting through at all
like they're getting sucked into the
wall much yeah
I set up employment lab just for fun
flame claps yeah
late they flap open and shoot play Oh
huh
the other bread number
but don't put that wait whoa whoa wait a
minute
what what what what ah the part I'm how
did we not get the part I'm we killed
everything at the doors how did you get
more kills than me cuz I'm awesome
amazing even uh I don't understand how
we could have beaten them any faster I
don't know we kill them all the doors
they never even got close whatever don't
matter anyway huh that's all the time we
got for this episode thank you all so
much for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next part
bye bye hi